hey
what's up bro
hey you coming to dallas
all right
jamal adams you never know when you're
going to encounter a citizen journalist
talking to a guy who captured the video
and put it on social media
adams was asked are you coming to dallas
he said i'm trying to bro hey look it's
about time for me to uh think about
trading in my truck i like that mercedes
that he was driving the g wagon that is
a nice ride uh and uh probably probably
more than i would want to spend because
those are not cheap but it's not going
to be cheap to get jamal adams chris
there are eight teams that he's told the
jets he's interested in playing for but
it's clear he wants to play for the
cowboys
yeah i mean it certainly seems that way
i i you know
yeah things went off the rails this past
few days with jamal adams the new york
jets so where he seems like he's given
up it's over he doesn't want to deal
with it anymore man
you know the dallas cowboys i don't know
if they can afford a guy like jamal
adams right now you know i know that
he's saying he'll go there and he won't
ask for you know a new contract well
eventually he's going to ask for it and
what's dallas going to have to give up
to get jamal adams jamal adams without a
doubt is the best safety in football for
my money i mean he is amazing he is a
hell of a player the jets shouldn't let
him out the door
the only thing i'll say mike too is like
where i want to say to jamal adams and
you correct me if i'm wrong here i just
want to go
there i don't see
contract extensions and negotiations are
not at a strong point in the nfl right
now you know we don't know where
anything's going so i guess i just feel
like maybe his expectations are a little
too high with this right now in the
current circumstances
well and you know the the other reality
is he's under contract for two more
years but we've seen players take that
stand like antonio brown and jaylen
ramsey and the other thing too is this
if the cowboys or anyone else trades for
this guy don't wait to do
the
the contract you got to do it on the way
in the door
what happened to the texans with laramie
tunstall look at what's going to happen
to the rams with jalen ramsey you got to
get that deal done when you do the trade
so you don't have that he's got more
leverage chris if you wait to do the
deal later
yeah no no doubt about it i get that and
i wouldn't mess with that because he's a
really good player
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports